en première question je comprends pas
alors j'aime beaucoup l'émission lors
des pros beaucoup pascal praud qui est
un ami enfin kitada mieux vaut que je
connais les chais et qu'est ce que ça
vient [ __ ] là-dedans ce débat dans
l'émission on pas bannir le prôner que
ce soit dans cette émission à écouter
vous demanderez ça pascal praud c'est
pas moi qui suis responsable de la ligne
éditoriale de leurs dépôts à ce titre la
victime mais non mais enfin en même
temps c'est un mec comme ça que ça fait
quand même grand bruit il repris par la
presse faisait longtemps qu'il ya des
bugs comme ça je n'ai pas cherché mais
moi je venais pas parce que vous êtes
devenu une star dans des commentaires
sociaux n'ont pas spécialement parce que
j'ai trouvé que c'était assez frustrant
finalement 7e cette manière de procéder
géré c'est comme si moi je vais vous
inviter à boire un thé chez moi et
callao pas de ma porte je vous disais
dégage alors dans ce cas là il faut pas
faux je vous aurais pas invitées à des
soirées coup de boule là comme si
quelqu'un de civiliser lassitude sur un
plateau il y avait des règles on va pas
revenir dessus on va voir ce que vous
avez dit shégués donc pascal praud hier
et une faute à mon nom mais bon c'est
quoi
voilà vous madame et si je n'en demande
pas tant les dix états oui c'est messi a
oui c'est le contraire à chaqra
exactement si vous pouvez si on pouvait
bien des cas le prénom le nom de jean
bessière rouge de même à moi je suis
attendu comme un messie mais quand même
tous les chroniqueurs qui est sur le
plateau de cyril je les aime pas je vais
pas leur dire par et vous non mais c'est
à dire que j'aime pas leurs idées mais
je le débat avec eux raquel garrido à
j'aime pas ça j'aime pas ses idées oui
non le débat d'idées c'est pas la même
chose ils viendraient en désaccord de
vue dire par toi mais je perdais celle
qui se prétendent de gaulle de guilde
dit celle qui s'aplatit devant un type
de simplement parce qu'il pèse 185
millions d'euros
voilà alors ils s'aplatissent car à
pattes devant la puissance financière et
la puissance il amusé du jamais vu
non non non il est pas l'impression
octobre alors il ya une des
chroniqueuses de pascal praud elisabeth
lévy directrice de la rédaction de
causeur alors faut savoir causeur il ya
des trucs qui sont à droite
elle sait pas à droite là c'est que la
cr on la voit même plus
rédaction de causeur et elle a dit elle
elle a dit qu on fonctionnait sur le
principe de l'humiliation
mais regardez bien ce qu'elle dit elle à
un comprennent croyait que booba en fait
était un chroniqueur dans l'émission en
exergue à coeur de l'émission je fonce
l'émission coûterait beaucoup plus cher
garder une porte avant de s'incliner
devant la force
moi ce que je trouve tout à fait
contestable dans cette émission c'est
qu'elle fonctionne sur le principe de
l'humiliation du qu'un chroniqueur
puisse exiger si vous voulez que
quelqu'un d'autre ne viennent pas ouais
être un principe qui devrait tout à fait
condamner à bon faut l'enlever le
minibar dans les eaux gelées importe
quoi mais c'est rien c'est juste
enlèvement nous voilà ça sera très bien
et donc jean messia juste vous avez dit
oh voilà vous avez vous avez parlé donc
de tps convenait sur smith et non alors
je tiens tout de suite ouais je tiens
tout de suite à vous rassurer je n'ai
rien contre vous personnellement puisque
de toute façon comme je les dis abouba
je vous le dis aussi à vous je ne vous
connais pas personnellement donc je n'ai
rien contre vous mais je vous aime bien
sympa l'avènement d'un d'une fois sur
l'autre on finit par se saluer les uns
les autres et c'est à la sortie du
plateau
j'ai rien je parle d'idées c'est à dire
que moi ce que je voulais dire par là
c'est que effectivement j'ai des idées
qui sont différentes des vôtres mais il
ne me viendrait pas à l'esprit de vous
sortir du plateau ou de refuser de
discuter avec vous ce truc qui est
devant moi
celle de samsung oui mais je vais plus
je peux m'en servir donc les gens sont
libres de dire ce qu'ils veulent alors
voulais pas je vais pas vous arrêter
dans ce que vous dites vous avez le
droit de penser ce que vous voulez
pensée dans vous vous excusez vous
excusez vous retirez vos propres quand
je m'excuse si je vous écris ça sur le
plan humain je m'en excuse mais sur le
plan des idées vous l'aimez pas mes
idées
ça se voit au frère et je vous condamne
pas pour ça oui je l'aimé pas les vôtres
mais littéral
on est en démocratie encore une fois le
désaccord n'est pas un crime
je crois que sans les français
apprécient ce genre d'émission c'est
aussi parce que j'aime ça non seulement
de le dire mais de l'écrire mais on peut
dire ce qu'on veut mais quand mon ami
cyril hanouna invite la porte parole des
identitaires fin qui d'autre l'a invité
non c'est donc donc ça veut bien dire
qu'il ya il ya d'abord un pluralisme et
je crois que le public à la fois de tpm
paix et de btp est beaucoup plus et
click mais un surcoût plus diversifiée
qu'on ne veut bien le croire ce qu'on
allait nous et quand vous voyez qu'on
nettoie sur terre ici j'ai exactement
mais quand on a 30 à 40 % de gens qui
votent pour des idées comme les miennes
ou proches des miennes
ça veut dire que quand vous sortez dans
la rue vous avez une chance sur trois
peut-être une chose même un peu plus de
croiser quelqu'un qui pense comme moi
qu'est-ce que vous avez du genre vous
allez l'ostraciser et le mettre au
goulag et intellectuels banon voulait
pas d'élections
jeanjean est ce que vous avez été je
voulais ce sens qui est ce que vous avez
été vexé oui oui j'ai été vexé
j'étais vexé disons que j'ai été vexé
parce que je n'avais pas été prévenus
que ça pouvait se passer si on m'avait
dit ça à la limite j'aurais intégré ce
risque et je serais venue ou pas mais je
j'aurai je serais venu en connaissance
de cause j'ai vu quatre plein de gens
qui vous ont dit pourquoi tu vas encore
dans l'émission de cyril hanouna après
ce qui s'est passé mais parce que
j'estime que encore une fois je pense
que vous êtes ici suffisamment
intelligent je l'espère pour pour
débattre avec quelqu'un qui n'est pas
forcément d'accord avec vous voilà ce
qu'ont fait tous les noirs et donc et
donc moi j'ai pas de problème avec le
débat d'idées vous savez le frottement
de cervelle c'est quelque chose de
typiquement français et c'est quelque
chose qui doit être apprécié nous sommes
dans une démocratie ni cervelle et la
démocratie enfin comment ce pardon par
le débat d'idées voilà alors moins ce
que j'aime pas par contre c'est
qu'effectivement et j'aurais on parle de
booba c'est qu'effectivement vous avez
sur ce type de plateau si quelqu'un est
catalogué d'extrême droite alors il va
falloir ce concours hippique ce qu'est
l'extrême droite
on l'a fabule de l'infamie de l'extrême
droite et tous de travers on lui rende
dans l'art en disant oh la la c'est
scandaleux veut menacer les libertés
individuelles les libertés publiques
dégager d'ici vous êtes un fasciste et
herat mais par contre lorsqu un discours
de haine
mais siam sous laon et donc lorsque
lorsque vous êtes lors lorsque les mêmes
propos même des propos largement
extrémistes des propos haineux contre
les femmes contre les homosexuels voir
contre les minorités sont portés par des
gens issus d'une certaine diversité là
tout le monde applaudit du tout génial
c'est pas le cas si les paroles ou bas
je suis désolé pour le cas ici ça n'a
rien à voir on est revenue ces messieurs
mais sierre vous me gênait beaucoup là
vous avez battu fait pour ça vous avez
beaucoup de défauts mais je pensais au
moins que vous étiez courageux hors jeu
maintenant revenons à faire ce choix je
m'aperçois que vous êtes lâche sur le
plateau de pascal praud vous ne nous
aimait pas on est des moins que rien ça
nous insultent ici vous arrivez vous
avez peur de nous donc non pas du tout
pourquoi c'est pas du tout les gens
rampaient nous avaient leurs idées
cyril hanouna qui vous invite à me suis
fait virer
dans les émissions lui c'est votre ami
parce que vous nous et vous venez de
dire mon ami cyril hanouna parce que
vous n'osez pas y toucher
et je vais vous expliquer que les gens
sachent qui vous est en réalité position
je vais vous expliquer ce que vous avez
fait sur les réseaux sociaux et quelles
sont vos méthodes
ouais c'est que vous avez lancé votre
chien contre moi sur les réseaux sociaux
ou les armes évidemment j'ai eu des
milliers de messages bien sûr saleh
d'atterrissage principal c'est de
combien et saint-just les seniors
messieurs vous avez télécommandé mais
arrêter et non j'avais fait un tweet
vous avez été malin et les gens ont
commenté j'ai eu des dessins je voulais
devrait même pas tellement c'est indigne
mais rien que pour ça rien que pour ça
ben franchement m'a donné vous avez usé
mais monsieur vous relevez vous êtes une
petite nature moi ça fait des mois
qu'ils sont lassés de morts par rapport
à l'aller une certaine diversité
encouragé par les gens de la bce d'eau
ne dis comme ça je vous la met sur le
dos ne dissimulent à ces deux bornes à
tous mes amis et mes enfants également
socialisme en afrique j'ai été contacté
par la plateforme pharos pour ça c'est
la plateforme pharos qui m'a contacté
alors arrêtez de jouer un jour sur les
réseaux sociaux il ya de tout j'ai un
des moyens mais siamois et monsieur
messier à pardon j'ai eu l'impression
qu'on vous êtes arrivé sur plateau avec
booba vous vouliez vous le faire et en
hommes et en os alors plus sur parlons
pas sur mon banc des pulsions
d'intervention chez pascal que oui mais
moi je pense qu'en fait tout ça vous
arrange en fait ça fait pas vous aimez
les terrains aussi vous aimez les
plateaux mines et non en fait
aujourd'hui vous venez pour dire pour
montrer que vous êtes un camp de la
tolérance du dialogue de l'échangé
d'avis et de points de vue
oui voilà et donc finalement vous mettez
les autres du côté de l'intolérance en
cause nous eh oui mais vous voyez bien
que c'est un calcul vous être calme ce
soir basse que d'habitude habitude quand
je viens de discuter au moins on
l'espère remplacer une alors si je crois
que c'est l'effet dissuasif patients de
ce champignon pour mongolito l'aller
vous disiez avec beaucoup de vélo vous a
toujours bien au-dessus temps d arrêter
en jeu mais l'entamé mais c'est la règle
du jeu moi je ne dis pas que je suis
malheureux sans moi je suis bien reçu
quand j'ai un débat intéressant et
contradictoire avec les gens mais je
savais pas bien regardé pas bien rejoint
en tournée dans le nord dans la
suffocation du politiquement tout son
froc ici non mais pas ici et d ailleurs
jamais sia avait dit si non il va
laisser je viens ici pour avoir un débat
intéressant dvd contradictoires
avoir des débats intéressants et non je
parlais de cette séquence là où j'ai été
empêchés de débattre et si vous étiez
effectivement les démocrates que vous
prétendez être un jour y est dû est
scandalisé par ces jeunes avaient éclaté
en mille regards étaient très mauvaises
non non j'ai pas été mais je n'ai pas pu
en placer une
vous avez très mal commencé j'avais
sorti mais on avait l'habitude excusez
moi je suis jamais d'accord avec vous
mais vous êtes bien meilleur là vous
étiez catastrophique
vous avez sortira que vous ne
connaissiez ni d'eve ni d'adam vous
l'aviez jamais écouté c'est son nouvel
enfant vous aviez des fiches par les
communes y attendais mais j'ai chez moi
je n'ai pas les moyens de payer des
communicants jean todt n'avait jamais ce
que du coût de ses costumes
ça c'est la première chose la deuxième
chose vous pouvez pas me faire ce procès
parce que là vous faites preuve d'une
mauvaise foi à couper au couteau
vous pouvez pas me faire ce procès quand
j'ai pas durer plus de deux secondes sur
le plateau général commencent à dénoncer
la mal commencé attendait mais c'est pas
gai temps il ya un débat pourquoi l'a
pas été aux jusqu'au bout on est allé
chercher des vieux scénario du jeu on a
déjà fait le dépôt type est un génie il
a réussi à monétiser un million d'euros
chaque mot de vocabulaire qu'il connaît
à arrêter parce que vous lui en voulez
satine qui est la plus jeune qu'à 16 ans
qu'est-ce que vous connaissiez géant
médias avant oui je connaissais un peu
du coup de btp mais si mais si non à ces
boues baosteel le slash ex boss salam a
des ambitions mais ça tout le monde en
parlait dans tout le ciel ça mais moi ce
que je voulais bientôt vous êtes
peut-être faire un feature est ce que
juste la barre et celle de laisser la
parole si vous permettez juste un
instant est jugée en valeur son avis je
peux vous dire je peux vous dire que vu
les réactions sur les réseaux sociaux et
même les gens qui aiment booba n'ont pas
trouvé ça très correct ni très courageux
de sa part à lui pas de ma part à moi
mais ces données réelles et jeu
effectivement et je le dis à tous les
spectateurs les téléspectateurs qui sut
qui sont issus de la diversité parce que
j'en ai ren croisé beaucoup y compris
des maghrébins ddd proche-orientaux il
me dit je n en sais quoi qui me tue je
sais pas s'ils sont français ou pas mais
j'ai un fou il me dit oh toi tu me dises
chez nous c'est raide mais ça veut dire
c'est mal hervé jean matches à jouer et
il ya des gens aussi qui lie sur les
réseaux sociaux je vous le dis c'est
irrespectueux d'avoir été cracher sur
l'émission et sur moi chez pascal praud
1 alors que c'est moi qui vous ai donné
énormément la parole avec bien sûr des
contradicteurs
avec qui à six lancés notamment qui est
un ami vous le savez yassine belattar
qu'irène amis
raquel garrido aussi voilà il ya des
gens qui disent aussi ça alors voilà
vous savez mais vous qu'est ce que vous
pensez vous savez très bien que j'ai
défendu le principe de l'émission encore
une fois sur une vidéo que tout le monde
peut aller voir sur ma chaîne youtube
est dans un régime publié dans causeur
d'ailleurs cet après midi à bâle où j'ai
défendu le principe de l'émission donc
ça on peut pas me faire le procès ne pas
avoir défendu le principe de cette
émission dans laquelle encore une fois
ça me fait beaucoup plaisir de venir
je suis sûr d'avoir en face de moi des
gens qui ne pensent pas comme moi et
donc c'est l'occasion d'avoir un débat
intéressant alors le débat intéressant
il faut qu'ils aient lieu vous pouvez
pas le seuil des 40 secondes de débats
sa team non alors m'a sincèrement je
pense que dans le cadre où vous bossez
avec notre à ce moment se croient
souvent dans les couloirs vous venez
souvent sur plateau vous ne pouvez pas
dire que vous nous détester parce que
déjà ça j'ai la lidia il a les atouts
pour l'instant c'est parce que je veux
dire c'est que effectivement pour moi
vous l'aviez dit pour tout le monde
autour de la table vous l'avez bien non
salut je dis pas ça ne se dit pas
surtout dans le milieu du showbiz ont
ensuite vous n'êtes du showbiz la
question je vais retourner la question à
tous les chroniqueurs et c est ce que
vous m'aimez non non non moi je vous
connais pas mais excusez moi mais on
peut très bien aussi refusé de débattre
avec vous moi il ya des gens annonce
d'avatar délai soit il ya des gens qui
pensent excusez moi que vous donnez la
parole ou de débattre avez-vous vous
rend meilleur
vous êtes a décidé d'aider des propos
des pensées qui ne leur correspond pas
et moi je suis désolé effectivement
quand on est des millions vous d'avoir
un vous souvenez vous savez jouer deux
secondes vous savez très bien faire vous
parlez très bien vous distillez votre
message
et moi je trouve que pour ce n'est pas
d'accord avec vous on peut aussi refuser
de débattre non parce que en place et
non mais une excusez moi en france une
idée ce combat avec une autre idée elle
se combat pas avec la prison du silence
c'est pas la prison moi je produis
réduisez quelqu'un violence voulant voir
deux minutes de débat donc krivine
choqués on va parler kelly mais pour moi
de base le débat il est faussé parce
qu'à partir du moment où vous invite
vous n'étiez pas au courant ça je suis
d'accord y'a pas de soucis mais vous
voyez bien qu'il un il un buzzer c'est
un jeu entre vous deux je vois pas
pourquoi nous on se fait attaquer alors
qu'on n'a strictement rien à voir avec
cet accord la lave nos valeurs
on nous dit de pillage ça fait
maintenant dix minutes ce débat vous
m'avez vu utiliser ce tournoi mais cela
avant par les deux je suis sûr de se
lamenter parce que si on déballe message
vous parle d'autre chose vous parle de
avant avant vous avez dit que vous avez
attaqué nous pourquoi vous attaquez pas
booba seulement nous les grandes cartes
mais c'est les marseillais qui font de
la politique
pas parce que vous revenez sur vos
paroles
vous avez dû vous avez dit blanc arrêter
avec ces sur nous non mais s'il vous
plaît je me fais insulter je peux parler
on n'a aucun rapport avec ce qui s'est
passé avec booba on était autour de la
table et dit qu'il n'avait pas résidé et
d'ailleurs c'est réciproque
je voulais dire dans la dernière chose
que je voulais dire c'est
qu'effectivement on reçoit beaucoup
certains représentants d'une diversité
qui est souvent anti national qui est
nous et heureusement attendez qu'elle
apporte au soir le côté quand on reçoit
rokhaya diallo conseiller vos pensées
pourquoi payer les gens que quand ils
s'envoient là n'est pas lâcher quoi vous
ne savez jamais les archers booba lui
les lois votées de la mêlée la joie
d'aller vous les reconnaissez mois de
janvier allez c'est pourquoi vous
recevez les fixes matinée les sonia
maltais
[Musique]
voilà les recevez jamais prises un cap
ce que pourrait laisser les nations nous
invite vous mais justement pas voilà bah
voilà ben oui et justement c'est pour ça
que je refuse je ne refuse jamais de
venir
je suis le seul ça c'est insultant et
non vous a jamais insulté c'est moi je
n'ai insulté personne et la réalité
monsieur c'est la règle du jeu aux
mâchoires d'internement où nous critique
jean messia et les invités critique jean
bessière il a le droit de nous critiquer
nous là on voit là vous vous trompez
monsieur mais ça c'est que cette
séquence vous n'avez pas du tout été
humiliée elle vous a pas desservis c'est
énormément parler tout le monde l'a vu
bon vous vous exprimez vous et non pas
alors je vous disiez que c'était comme
ça on a beaucoup plus parlé de vous avec
cette séquence comme si vous aviez mené
derrière normal mais chacun doit elle a
été vue plus vous êtes venue le
lendemain vous expliquer mais cher
monsieur je n'en revenais aujourd'hui je
voulais je vous le dis de manière très
républicaine j'en ai strictement rien à
[ __ ] d'avoir serré je me plains pas ce
que je suis venu de débattre je suis pas
venu pour me faire virer que mal ma
propre âme à un malpropre vous avez
débattu devant la troisième fois qu'on
bourse a pour nom met d'accord après
mais cette séquence bah oui mais
attendez je tiens le même préciser que
c'est pas moi qui m'invitent moi-même
d'accor services et c'est à vous inviter
bien sûr il tout à fait sensé et
personnes pourraient forcer ekwalla moi
je ce que je comprends pas de votre part
c'est vous dites qu'on vous aime pas
d'avoir vous en ce vous en savez rien on
n'est pas là pour vous aimez ou pas la
changer la version - paris le vrai moi
avec vous je vais vous dire c'est très
simple j'ai rien contre vous il ya juste
un problème si vous avez un fonds de
commerce qui est toujours le même et
vous n'existait que sur la polémique je
ne vous ai encore jamais vus proposer
des choses concrètes avec vous avez vous
n'avez pas lu alors à gauche à droite
dans tous les sens on est en train de
naître ne vous est criant vous mettez à
feu
plein de problématiques que les
politiques et tout le monde essaye de
gérer depuis des années mais de l'autre
côté vous n'a pas arrosé
voilà mon problème aujourd'hui et vous
n'existez que comme ça enfin du tout si
vous voulez moi j'ai pas j'ai pas choisi
d'être une bête de télé si vous voulez
moi j'ai un boulot
il est le roi du raï vous êtes vraiment
sonné attend dsk jeu il est le roi du
buzz il fait que buzz et booba il avait
raison c'est qu'il attendait mais vous
êtes vous êtes à vous et vous pratiquez
une cécité militante les amis c'est
possible c'est pas moi qui ai c'est pas
moi qui use et ce2 de ce truc au bo avec
voix qui l'a jamais benjamin quand 8i on
a droit de pas débattre avec monsieur
messier dans ce cas là on ne l'invité
pas sur le bâtiment mais c'est un joli
la règle jeu oui mais voilà bah si c'est
un débat qui dure six secondes ça sert à
rien même si son désaccord il a parlé
tout à l'heure je me suis pas permis de
l'interrompre
en tapant sur surtout les classes on
n'était pas les choses cyril vous êtes
vous aimez bien quand les gens ne sont
pas langue de bois moi je vous ai bien
aimé ne nous dira je ne vous aime pas et
après d'avoir le cran de venir ici
peut-être de le dire cette fois à demi
mots mais vous aimez bien cyrille voilà
quand les gens disent la vérité après il
y avait exigé aussi booba les arrêts du
jeu c'était de buzzer si c'est juste je
réfère avec nos enfin je répète je n'ai
rien contre vous personnellement il ya
un certain nombre d'entre vous que je
vois après il nous y nous on se salue la
maniabilité mais bien aucun problème et
on a le droit effectivement booba a le
droit de ne pas aimer mes idées vous
avez le droit de ne pas aimer mes idées
comme quand je vous ai posé la question
d'ailleurs vous vous avait été pris de
crises tonico cloniques parce que vous
saviez pas répondu moi je vaux je vous
pose la question nous répondait pas moi
je vous dis que j'aime pas vos idées et
vous êtes ne vais pas vous le connaissez
vous
on va voir ce qu'en pensent ses
téléspectateurs et ou s'il vous plaît
oui à 35% renom à 65% voiliers ou pas
donc née voilà mais c'est vrai que moi
aussi je trouve n'avait pas été trop
loin non voilà dans le crime n'avait pas
été trop lents et moi je suis assez
d'accord avec les téléspectateurs guinée